how's it going everyone we wanted to get
a guide together for newer for nine
players and enlist some you veterans out
there for more advanced combat building
tips we're gonna cover building for
mobility and how to make your first
panic fort then end with some ideas for
towers in the final circle so if you
want to be competitive here's what you
need to know when pubsey players first
started playing fort night battle royale
they pretty much did a lot of the same
tactics but over time people have gotten
really good at building and destruction
you can build using wood from trees and
sheds brick from rocks and buildings and
metal from cars and appliances when
using these materials keep in mind wood
can be destroyed quickly but is most
abundant and best for fast traversal
brick and metal are much more resistant
to being shot out and make the best
forts and towers as you play a match a
battle royale you should always be
gathering resources while keeping in
mind that doing this is really loud and
noisy so pause periodically check your
surroundings and make sure to listen the
first type of construction to master is
combat movement and the ramp is your
main weapon ramps are perfect for
climbing up and over hills descending
mountains by flipping them in reverse
attacking up and over enemy forts hey
just for fast cover deception and bind
ramps let you get high which gives you
the advantage in most gunfights floors
are ramps best friend they'll let you
travel between buildings across chasms
and link to forts all shapes can be
placed on the floor and edited and the
most modifications aren't worth the time
it takes it can be fun to play with one
modification you definitely should learn
is to make a door by editing two squares
in a wall so that you never get trapped
in your own building you can also edit
shapes even after they've been placed
ramps can also be made into stairs by
editing the template into a u-shape this
allows you to go straight up from the
base of a mountain when you're trapped
by the final circle the only other
really notable item in the game for
getting around is the bounce pad which
you may find randomly in the environment
the balance pad can be placed on a floor
and will eject players into the air
allowing them to open their glider and
go long distances it's the closest thing
you'll find to a vehicle from pub G
once you've mastered those basic shapes
you're ready for panic forts which is
what you build when somebody shoots at
you and you have no idea where they are
to make the basic fort put up one or two
ramps in a v-shape then add one two two
stories of walls on top of it while on
top of your ramp leap up and lay down
more ramps below you which makes your
fort stronger and prevents people from
coming up from under you you'll use the
same template for taller towers and it's
a great way to get building into your
muscle memory speaking of if you've
collected some good loot made it to the
final circle and now all the players
around you are suddenly going vertical
before heading up yourself understand
how to cut down enemy forts the new mini
gun makes this a lot easier as well as
explosives aimed at the base this is
because if you shoot out the bottom of
the fort you can actually drop the
entire thing also if the enemy team is
building up and out shoot out the floor
from beneath them to drop them out of
their own Tower and do some damage when
it comes time to building your own Tower
make sure the base is made of stone or
metal so it's less likely to be taken
out from under you use the same method
as your panic for it to build high then
at the top flip some ramps into an open
bowl your fort will end up looking a bit
like a flower this is a great bill for
playing with squads
with wide commanding views of an entire
area and that you get you started with
combat building in fortnight veteran
players what fortifications do you like
in the final circle let's talk tactics
in the comments below and hopefully
we'll see you before you see us out on
the battlefield thanks for watching
[Music]